I done print modeling underwear Fitness
done a lot of runway print mostly for
new designers in the LA area I have
never had braces I had braces for three
years from the end of eighth grade up
until about junior high school my teeth
were atrocious there was I could fit a
straw between my two front teeth I love
the end result I wish it didn't have to
last three years I think braces is just
kind of like a whatever thing and people
make it out to be a big deal and so I'm
like oh well I'll try it out I don't
think it's gonna faze me at all I'm
excited about it
put your ball right oh I have so much
saliva in my mouth look at them that's
just like they are I can't really smile
I got the reaction from friends and I
thought I would wear they would just
crack jokes and ask me if I was going to
puberty
look at these braces oh my god are they
actually think those are fake eat it
look ridiculous beautiful they're being
if you want straight teeth you got it
you got to suffer for a little bit it's
all it's all you can do no one has
really been crazy I've been smiling
because I really can't close my mouth
there was a time where I did run my
tongue across my teeth and with the
braces on and it did give me some
flashbacks to cutting my tongue or my
lip or actually having braces which was
a pain oh my god I just woke up I did
hurt so not showing on based on facial
expressions I don't think people really
reacted or cared I went everywhere and
nobody really like looked at me
differently they didn't care that I had
them they weren't like why do you have
braces nobody really talked about it be
confident in your own skin and like I
said braces aren't forever you'll get
them off and the end result is
definitely worth it
[Music]